Not many people know that the oldest rum distillery in the US is in New Orleans.
If you love drinking, why not try a rum tour?
You should try Cajun Spiced Rum,...
...which has been voted the best flavored rum on the market...
...for the second year running.
For only 10 dollars, you can attend a tour starting at 10 AM, 1 PM and 3 PM daily.
Included is a sample of their specialty drinks.
On a hot day, you can also try the Cajun Iced Tea!
During the tour, through the distillery, you can taste all of their products.
Naturally, you can buy any of the products right there,...
...including a 10-year-old rum that you cannot purchase anywhere else.
The company holds a number of special events,...
...such as happy hour and they cater for parties.
A visit there is a unique and interesting experience,...
...something different from all the other tourist haunts in New Orleans.